you
hello folks
another day another lecture we've been
looking at quantum mechanics for the
last couple day weeks and we kind of
encroached on to philosophy and
rationality that's where we stand today
and I want to cover those three subjects
also because they are related and I'm
gonna try to relate them what I say
today and we start with what philosophy
is and again the issue is that we have
no definition no formal definition from
the establishment of what philosophy is
philosophy is defined in terms of
knowledge truth these are the words they
use they've been around for 2,000 years
so I don't think that they're gonna
change much and I don't think philosophy
has anything to do with knowledge or
truth i define in order in order to
incorporate philosophy within science
for it to have meaning
it's got explain something that's what I
say okay you don't have to agree I'm
just saying this is my point of view I'm
saying that the word philosophy you know
what we usually typically typically
think of philosophy is is has no meaning
unless it explains something and
assuming that it's true assuming we
accept that overall picture we have
something for physics which is you know
physics what does physics display
science is rational explanation right so
what does physics explain well physics
explain things related to objects and
related to mechanisms causes so what
then does philosophy explain under that
format under that general picture well
then philosophy is supposed to explain
concepts
or reason and/or reasons and purposes
what do you mean by explain concepts I
thought concepts were the only things we
had to explain no no there's more than
that laying objects that they just
pointed to them no no no VA yeah okay
let's clarify that in physics you know
we don't explain objects you cannot
explain an object you can you can
describe an object but only after the
person know what's what objects you are
referring to if if the if you point to a
chair you point to a table you name it
you say chair or tape or whatever
now the cling-on the et de Martian
doesn't work okay well make it simpler
here someone on earth a foreigner a
Chinese you know he knows the word chair
you know he understands the word chair
because you say chair maybe he doesn't
need to know how to spell it but you say
chair now he associates the sound with
what you pointed to that's how he learns
the nouns you can't do that with
concepts you can't do that with love you
can't point to love and say love my
point right very okay let's complete let
me complete the picture it's important
to complete the picture but it's a valid
question in other words in physic under
the physics branch of science okay let's
put that up there yeah here it is here's
a science chart okay and under rational
rational science means rational
explanation that's what science were
saying that's what science is about
science is not about describing
observing making predictions running
experiments none of that science is only
about one thing and one thing only
that's
explaining a mechanism explaining a
theory or an irrational expansions it's
divided into two parts it's divided into
physics and philosophy
what does physics dude that's what we're
discussing now we're saying yeah
physics deals with objects causes and
mechanisms what are we talking about
we're saying that first you have to
identify the object okay hopefully
that's clear we point to a table that's
that's gonna be the actor in our theory
yeah yeah
what are we explaining no no we don't no
no no hold it okay okay all right you
can explain no no we're not explaining
objects obviously objects are see
physics that has to be treated a little
differently than philosophy physics
deals with objects you can't do physics
without an object I call that the golden
principle the golden rule you can't do
physics without an object physics
requires an object and you can't explain
object you can only point to them so in
the case of you know here we have a
separation between philosophy and
objects and physics I'm sorry objects
you point to concepts you explain okay
so the those are different in fact
concepts you do more than explain you
define you have to define the concepts
yeah objects in fact that's the answer
to your question we don't really explain
up the concepts we define them
we have criteria for them so objects we
point to concepts we define okay what
we're going to explain are the causes
and mechanisms on the physics side and
the reasons and purpose on the
philosophy side okay so so let's divide
it like that that's that's what we're
proposing but what is the issue the
issue is if philosophy is gonna have any
kind of meaning if we're gonna make
sense of philosophy you know what is the
point of philosophy in my if I'm gonna
just say well you know I have my own way
of
I called it my philosophy and I believe
that you know Superman is real he flies
and and you know and Snow White did
exist you know I can come up with a lot
of stuff right and the question the word
wrong the way that most people use it
they use it philosophy like this as a
synonym for the way I use the word Creed
yeah yeah okay I mean I'm getting to
that but my point is that we use it in
many ways we say what is your philosophy
and a person says well my philosophy is
that you know you got to live life yeah
drink beer that's my philosophy one way
of making sense of the world no I mean
that that would be a way of rephrasing
that question instead of using the word
philosophy instead of saying what is
your philosophy or theory the asking is
how do you make sense right and that's
one aspect of callosity another one will
be you know you might say how should I
live you know Buddhists they like to do
give recommendations on how you should
live and you should do the asanas you
know all these yoga postures and so on
and you should be one with a universe
that's their philosophy and you say okay
I understand your philosophy your way of
thinking essentially for the word
philosophy reduces to way of thinking
and I'm saying that's not philosophy has
got nothing to do with philosophy only
because if we're going to incorporate
philosophy within science it's got to
explain something and if you just tell
me look this is the way you've got to
live you got drink beer you got to do
yoga you got to be one with the universe
you're not you're not explaining
anything you're just giving me your
opinion your recommendation how I should
live but aren't you essentially just
explaining really just categories
categorizing how you use the word yeah
yeah there's no clarification yeah yeah
let's make sure
Claire is you don't have to clarify how
people have been using the word or how
people understand the word it's really
just this is how I defined the word well
I I go back to the other because people
say well that's not what the meaning is
of philosophy and that's why I bring the
traditional notion in there to compare
to contrast and compare I'm saying that
you know what we used to think of
philosophy where you're thinking that's
not what I'm proposing I'm saying that
if it's got to fit within science it's
got to explain and it's you can't just
be way of thinking okay so you don't
have to you don't you don't have to
agree with me I'm just saying please
ensure that you understand the
difference between way of thinking and
explanation I like the difference that
that makes the clear distinction because
usually philosophy has two definitions
really it's its way of living way of
thinking or creed which is kind of a
recipe yeah they also use it for the
explanation for why that Creed works or
why that philosophy works and why that
way of thinking works really you're only
extracting the second one the
explanation of concepts or way of living
a way of thinking just the explanation
like if I say I'm gonna eat you know a
healthy diet for example damn Creed
right as if that's recommendation it's
my balloon see yeah but then you say
that's not philosophy philosophy is the
part where you say okay why am I just
going to help me you know that would
explain your reason not the recipe
itself right should be itself falls
under religion because it might not be
the right philosophy it might not be
that might be good for you not for me
I'm all besides the explanation part
yeah and that's the distinction there
between between recipes and the
explanation of the recipe
well the recipe is just the
recommendations a belief I'm saying that
my recipe on how to best make the best
cake in the world is this one right it's
always followed by an expert
no no not necessarily see you see people
just say look this the one that tastes
best for me you know you and you stop
there you know this the best cake the
best cake is to do it this way Apple pay
or apple pie no no why and that's my
point I'm saying that it's not let me
finish let me finish I'm saying that if
I say look the best way to make an apple
pie is this way can I give you the
recipe so much sugar so much wheat flour
so many apples right this is the best
way and you say why is that the best way
no no no hold on we may not be hold on
we made not yet hold it hold it we may
not know no hold it hold it you're
jumping the gun you may not be doing
philosophy because the guy said why are
you recommending that specific recipe
because it's the one that tastes the
best we're still an opinion we still
haven't given an explanation okay I'm
just saying this person says this is the
one that tastes best for me the sort of
recommendation I give the recipe that I
give and why do I give it because it's
the one that tastes best for me okay but
he okay but yeah okay in a way he is
arrested but he says what because why
I'm giving the recipe could it could be
different things yeah but yeah correct
okay I you're right in that sense in
other words the person is saying it
tastes best for me that's his reason but
another reason could be it's healthy
yeah so and that's more objective-c
because if the guy says no hold it hold
it hold on oh you hold it because they
were both under explanation
but if the explanation is based on
subjective like it pays best for me it's
that really a good explain if you say
look it's it's a healthy and you go on
and it's described why it's more healthy
that that would sound like a rational
explanation but if you say look because
it tastes good for me and it's like
eluding the issue
it's like saying this is my opinion it
tastes good for me and that's not really
a good explanation of why you're
justifying it to some degree but it's a
subjective explanation it's not one it's
like saying my opinion is yeah it tastes
good to me but that's different than
saying the reason I'm proposing it is
it's healthier or it's got to make you
live a hundred more years or whatever
see the problem with one we're talking
about philosophy is all kind of
subjective not totally again did you see
the difference there between saying it
tastes good for me i like it i like it
and no because I like it and I think
it's healthy is it I believe it's
healthy yeah yeah and again when you put
the word believe yeah but see when you
put the word bull beef you're going into
religion remember opinion belief
religion no no Holden listen all I'm
saying is that it's different to say in
philosophy right an explanation where
you say I like it versus saying look the
reason is this it's healthier for
example right you're not saying that you
believe it's healthier you're just
saying look it's healthier for these
reasons it increases your lifespan
whatever so you're giving you an
objective explanation why proposing that
recipe that's different than saying look
it's because I like it it tastes better
for me no no no no no no remember the
difference is that when you say you're
now saying I believe it's healthier you
think someone knows it no no no no I'm
not saying the doctors right
none of that I'm saying look it's
healthier because the carbohydrates that
it includes in the wheat or in the flour
makes you live letter longer for this
reason I could say something like that
no no you're presenting an objective
explanation of why you you're
recommending that recipe so far it's all
objective it doesn't even mean that you
believe in it because you say you know I
don't I don't even eat apple pie you can
say that yeah yeah yeah you got to be
careful not encroaching into the belief
area because you're it's an assumption
but what I'm saying is so far you've
given an egg an objective yeah you gotta
hold on with that word because it's
still all I believe it's healthy or I
believe the car behind just do this it's
not because I can I see action no no our
hydrants under these circumstances help
you live longer no I can present a
theory the theory of relativity I can
present in physics I can present the
theory of relativity and say this is
what the theory of relativity says it
doesn't mean that I'm gonna believe that
I personally like the theory of
relativity I'm gonna present it that
doesn't mean I believe and and hold it
same here
if I give you a recipe for how to make
an apple pie and I'm saying the reason
for this is you know I could be
referring to what doctors say and I
collected all this information and I
kind of synthesize it and I'm saying you
know doctors say that the reason you
should eat apple pie under these
conditions under this recipe is because
you're gonna live a longer life you know
I can say that you're just passing the
buck on no no no no no but it means that
you're just from your presenting a
theory objectively so far you have any
said whether they believe you believe
you're just saying the statistics show
blah blah blah these things believe no
it's just saying that look these guys
did a study and this is what they came
out objectively it doesn't even mean
that the doctors believe in it maybe
they were shocked by the results for all
we know you know they they might be say
[ __ ] you know this this throws away my
own religion I did believe in this you
know it could be and maybe they don't
even accept that but they say you know
these are the fact this is what the
objective the data show okay well
objective I'm saying well subjective is
again I'm saying that subjective it has
to do with observe observation belief
opinion again subjective is what made a
subjective is religion that's religion
do religion you can say it's subjective
it's it's what you believe in what you
what your opinion is about something
whereas objective means that you're just
gonna present the case it doesn't even
mean that you believe in in that case
you know defense lawyer or a prosecutor
for that matter could be presenting the
other person's case and say look the
defense's arguing this it doesn't mean
that you believe it it means that you're
gonna present their case so that people
understand what their case is about and
and at that point it doesn't mean that
you believe in it you're saying I'm
gonna present a theory I'm going to
present the relativity theory or quantum
mechanics theory it doesn't mean I
believe in it I'm saying I'm gonna
present it so that you understand what
these people are proposing yeah but is
that objective its objective in this how
we use the word objective objective we
don't use it in context of explaining
what when I'm saying when I'm saying
that you know what Breezies two magnets
together you know is threads that are
spinning around
it doesn't mean you
mean that I believe in it I'm just
saying I'm gonna present a mechanism so
that you understand it and that's
objective you don't even know so far
whether I believe in it or not hold on
hold on I think the difference what
you're trying to point out uh huh is
because when you bring up the magnets
it's the self-explanatory part that's
objective when you have a video of
dominoes hitting each other that's
objective because it's self-explanatory
it's kind of what I mean is it
understands the mechanism
well because I'm saying that this is
observer free in the sense that I'm not
trying to convince you I'm not trying to
persuade you I'm saying this is what
happened
this is what I what I think is what
happened now it doesn't mean I believe
in and you're presenting a you're
presenting a mechanism you're presenting
a way that it could have happened that's
the okay fine it would have happened
that's fine I'll accept that is
subjective right could I happen to
subject right okay well I think that's
that's the the key point that I was
looking okay because when you're trying
to brainstorm you're basically looking
at what are all the ways it could have
happened if you have the whole list of
all the pockets all the good all the
goods yes basically objective is a list
while subjective is one of those yeah
okay and and that's good the could have
happened this way is the objective part
because you're not you're not really
you're you you could be brainstorming
you could be presenting five different
theories so it could have happened this
way this way this way in that way right
you could present all that and again
you're not you're not giving you an
opinion just saying look these are the
possibilities I like that you know on
the other hand under hand whenever I use
is picking one of them yeah is this the
one I recommend the recipe that I
recommend or or this is what I happen
out of all the different possibilities
of the crime scene there's no one
and that's what the prosecutor or the
defendant says correct but the one that
they want for their on occasion make
something objective is the could shoot
should know it's the goods versus the
deeds yeah okay it's okay they could
rest of the dish basically saying
something objectively
is we brainstorm in real time here by
the way okay so that's objective because
we're basically looking for is
brainstorming is the essence of
objectivity because you're basically
listening out okay what are all the
possibilities right then then you're
gonna hit everyone subjective one but
objectively speaking you're hitting all
of them so by definition there's no bias
because you're literally looking at
alright there's no bias that's important
object area can be no bias if you hit
all the possibilities yeah and and
that's the point the point is that in
philosophy okay when you say yeah when
we say philosophy or subjective or
philosophies objective we really might
mean no no for example I'll give you an
example and let's start with an example
and I always know Polian porta pull you
a little present
yeah yeah yeah why did he go to the
Waterloo in 1815 and you can come up
with ten different reasons and you can
say though he went there because his
wife chased him away he wanted to die he
wanted glory you can come up with a
whole bunch of lists all the
brainstorming that you can think of
that's the objective and that's the
objective part and you can come up with
all these theories right of why he went
to water right and then the this guy the
subjective guy says oh he went there
because well now he's being subjective
now he picked one out of all those
reasons and yeah in that sense then you
get into religion as long as you present
you know different theories and you can
contrast and compare them I think you're
being objective okay are you being
objective because normally in the way
presentations work yeah
yeah the way presentations work is you
don't really present all of them know
right
normally the way it works is you present
one one right but it doesn't mean you
believe in that was that considered
objective I'm sayin though you're not
presenting all of them yeah I think it
is again when you talk about how magnets
work yeah you're being objective in the
sense that stands alone let's break that
down
why is that objective even when you're
not explaining all of them because I
don't need I don't mean your hand going
yeah yeah I don't need to compare it
against quantum I don't need now people
are not even supposed to be aware of
what quantum proposes to understand what
I'm proposing I'm saying look this is a
mechanism you can say I'm proposing it
or johny proposed it and I'm copying I'm
just regurgitating it it doesn't matter
but the point is I present a mechanisms
that do you understand this mechanism
and its objective in the sense that
you're only concentrated in the
mechanism and under not on the evidence
proof I think in my opinion none of that
you're just concentrating on mechanism
do I understand the mechanism is a
different criteria for objectivity
yeah because one is this two notions one
is this a brainstorming yeah I'm getting
down all of the versions but then
there's this other form of objective
which is more what is your what do they
call it a crime scene was his intention
purpose no the one they used in crime
scene that starts with them like it's
more on what his motives motive yeah
you're getting old that happens to
people like me not their kids see the
way you use objective in that sense when
you're saying what I propose is this and
I just want you to understand in that
sense you use the word objective because
you're more interested in them
understanding and not believing alright
how is that objective yeah yeah you said
it perfect
perfectly let's repeat what you said I'm
not interested in someone believing I'm
interested in people understanding
there's a lot of people who believe they
haven't understood my theory and so what
is the worth of that what is the value
of that I would known okay but but but
it just gives you an idea that I would
prefer much let's rather have a person
understanding and disagree this belief
and that a person believe and not
understand
okay so back to the word objective yeah
what does them understanding instead of
believing have to do with objectivity is
that the right word for that I I think
it is because if the person just
understands you know so far you don't
even know what is what's going to his
mind you know if he's accepted or not I
figured my son figured it out hold on
stop the world because the objective
part is they have the brainstorm part it
goes back to the brainstorming or
listing out all the possibilities you're
trying to put one into their
possibilities that they haven't thought
of yet okay basically if their list
didn't come up with that one and now
you're including one more very
interested in putting it in there so
that they picked that one as their
favorite you're just Institute
interested in them seeing it in their
list right including it in their lips
yeah it's like it's like your list isn't
complete until that one's in there so
you're more interested in just putting
the thing in there bringing it bringing
it to their work consider this one as
well yeah and and yeah yeah so so that's
the way we want to really look at this
we want to say that you know there are
different theories and as long as you
are able to compare all of these
theories and find out which one you like
the best which is your personal religion
right fine but the point is the
important part is to understand them
yeah you have because there are people
who believe in quantum theory they don't
understand it they don't understand a
lot of what quantum says because it's
just too complex and people say oh I
love quantum
you understand it do you know what
quantum is saying they don't hear
because you don't have to understand it
for it to be your favorite one he goes
back no no but then then we have a
Bronto B then we have a problem that is
the religion part were yeah recipes and
you pick one out and you're not sure why
that is your favorite one you haven't
put a fine point on it because the phd's
tell me so yeah yeah but that's just
when it comes down to Oh thority the one
that you picked the subjective is the
religion part because you don't need an
explanation you don't have to understand
at all I'm trying to say is you don't
have to understand the one that you pick
strangely enough for religion no no no
but anytime you're thinking is religion
yeah correct
so anytime you're thinking is you don't
have to understand all of them yeah yeah
and that is true in other words you
don't have to understand the one that
you pick and whether you understand it
or not it's still religion it's the one
you picked let's just use an example if
you have if someone says okay what is
the healthiest food Nora right huh
objectively what you do I salute you
let's start all the food do you know ice
cream that's one of them is the only one
so you have a huge list of all the food
in the world
I'm how many considered food that's the
list of objectives healthy foods and
then when someone asks you what is the
healthiest food you know then you pick
one that's the religion for an opinion
right not not an explanation and
injective and that happens also in
politics and economics and so on you
have the explanation and you have the
selection it's the one that you opt for
it goes back to science when I asked you
if all questions are scientific
questions and you said no and goes back
to that and you're right it does I mean
have to question more than after
questions even in the physics side of
Cora you're more opinion based like yeah
science say the best my dog Anya
these things that are more subjective in
the sense that they're looking for your
opinion we have the idea of a possible
one but no one cares about the
possibilities they're more caring and
they're more interested in what's the
one that everyone's voting on yeah yeah
and and that's part of the problem in
fact that is a major problem because
people cannot distinguish between the
religion the belief opinion part and the
objective like you know this is the
these are the choices yeah yeah and and
again before I was rudely interrupted by
my son yesterday and today you know it
all started with my article against not
against really I was favoring roger
penrose who said string theory is
fashion quantum physics is faith and
cosmic inflation general relativity is
fantasy and you know Roger Penrose he's
in his 70s I believe and this fella you
know he's a celebrity of mathematical
physics and this is what is he saying
he's saying you know he's having doubts
about his own religion the things that
he was raised and educated with he's
saying you know straight theory you know
stick around you know quantum mechanics
maybe cosmic inflation nonsense you know
so so he's he's essentially dismissing
all these parts which are so critical
today for all these different branches
of mathematical physics now this is a
mathematical physics is who's rejecting
mathematical physics he's doing it in a
subtle very if if those statements are
his I I have to believe that they are I
know I haven't verified that they are
but assuming they are his it's a very
important point because this guy is
saying you know after so many years and
listening to so much nonsense out there
these are the conclusions to which I
reached and that is that a lot of this
is nonsense
and coincidentally that's the same
conclusion Einstein reached by the end
of the 40s beginning of the 50s he reads
the same conclusion as he was working at
Princeton that mathematical physics was
nonsense he couldn't make sense of it
and he also saw what was going around
you know around all the new generations
coming up with new ideas new particles
new new explanations which he did not
agree with and so you know it kind of
makes you wonder you know is this a
natural progression you know you
graduate you get your degree when you're
I don't know 30 years old fine you got
your PhD in mathematical physics now you
have a career you have a good salary
they they recommend you for a university
professor ship or whatever I don't care
you know so you go out there you do your
job and you investigate you do research
you listen to people you go to
conferences and after 20 30 40 years you
finally you know now you're 70 and now
you say you know it's all nonsense
should we listen to the older folk or
should we listen to the kids who come
out out of college thirty year old kids
who who say Oh quantum mechanics Oh
general relativity or should we listen
to the over thing you know I'm sick
[Laughter]
you're never too young to teach and
you're never too old to learn yeah
really and you know and and there's
another more important saying we have it
in in South America or in Argentina at
least and it goes something like this
the devil knows because he's the devil
but more he knows because of his age
because of his heat because he's old
and and that's an important point you
know the we know because we're Devils we
study we people well yeah yeah for sure
but but more we know because we are old
we do we gain experience over the years
and we say you know something is wrong
do you think later in life do you think
that when people get older later in life
like Einstein or Penrose or Bill Goethe
secret like they they kind of want to
know the truth because now they're not
interested in career money now they
really want to get to the bottom of it
yeah and that's I think part of that's
the issue the issue is you know the
older folk you know in the old days they
used to you know at least an oriental
philosophy or religion and they used to
deal with the sages no they would go to
the wise men who were the wise men were
the 15 year old kids no those are the
old people they were the 60 year olds
the 70 year olds you know the older folk
and they said you know wise man please
please help me I want to know this I
want to know that give me a
recommendation how to live or whatever
and these were the people who knew you
who have seen many riots because of the
moons that this guy lived that his
recommendation was valuable you weren't
gonna see a 20 year old because the the
20 year old is hasn't lived enough he
may be sharp maybe an intelligent guy
and he's picking up stuff over the year
maybe he did research but he hasn't
really mastered experience revolution
yeah because the old people what goes
along with that is kind of this
corruption where they hold on to things
that aren't true just because they've
hold held onto it for so long
and then there's this new Bloods coming
and the old people die often is like
okay this is the dumb part of what like
they take the good
but they kind of see the dumb part yeah
it's like that's true old kind of like a
generated generational sifting yeah and
there's another saying along those lines
that says that you know theories die
when the old people die in other words
the new theories come in they are able
to take their place because the old
people who supported the old theories
they died and so there's no one else to
support it so so you know you can get
this from every angle but a big downside
yeah a lot of traditions we don't know
how to live it goes back to the
philosophy that's why this I mean that's
why I think there's so many philosophy
videos nowadays because traditions
aren't passed on as well as they used to
be or they or they are not applicable in
this day it also be but everyone's
coming out of the Woodworks with
philosophy they all live like this live
like that eat like dizzy like that
anyways the point here is that you know
let me tell you how this debate or these
issues came to the fore and as I put an
article right and someone criticize
about Roger Penrose the fact that he was
criticizing essentially he was
criticizing more than criticizing he was
kind of being very skeptical about
mathematical physics all the branches
string theory quantum mechanics general
relativity and I put an article in there
now today as of today it's got 3,000
hits so it was a little bit of popular
in there right and this guy Joey
McKinley he comes up and he's a little
upset about it and he's not the only guy
there's a few guys who liked what he
said okay and he says your entire post
is an argument from incredulity you
assert that quantum theory is nonsense
yeah I do okay you got that part right
and put two examples of what you cannot
accept as rationale all right he got
that right even though there are
experimentally verified equation
describe precisely how these physical
entities work so there's a difference
there because I'm talking about
rationality and Heath he equates
rationality with experimentally verified
you know or describing physical how they
work you know none of that has to do
with rationality I have defined
rationality and so he says he continues
but you don't actually demonstrate or
prove that they're irrational no you
don't prove irrationality you define
irrationality and then if something is
rational it meets those spec meets the
conditions of your definition and it's
irrational by definition not because I
proved it to you proof means I'm gonna
twist your arm I'm going to try to
convince you Boone don't do that in
science we define rationality and then
we find out if something is rational and
they continue show how quantum theory
fails to meet that definition and again
he's confusing his proving rationality
versus defining rationality okay is it
is it not rational to use a theory that
works no it's not I don't care if it
works or not we define rationality we
defined irrationality we don't care if
it works or not we we just say let's
what what do we mean by irrationality so
the guy is really dealing with two
different subjects here with with what
works are this partners where they were
taught they you know very irrational
things at the afterlife and so on but it
got them to the to the battleground it
worked he got them to fight harder
because they think that there's an
afterlife that they're gonna go to so so
what works could also be rational right
it could be rational or irrational you
know you know angels work they move the
earth around the Sun did you know that
no that's not what he means by work
work as in there is a benefit to
believing that okay that's that's one
that's one aspect the other one is
technology old it the other one is
together that's that's what I'm saying
in with technology is the philosophy
version of technology versus science
there's technology versus science and
under philosophy it's it's creamers
philosophy because with creed it could
you you could have Creed the worse but
the explanation for it is irrational
again like the Spartans their Creed is
you know go to war died a hero
but the irrational explanation is you
get you know an afterlife yeah yeah
women was the sender sons officially but
they're also their husbands to war
saying come with your shield or on it
[Laughter]
women philosophically speaking it
doesn't make sense it's an irrational
philosophy but the Creed works and
that's kind of what are you saying are
you saying well it works so so it must
be rational that's that's a right and
again and I'm like well yeah it right
NSE issued its non sequitur and and and
that's the point the point is
rationality is not something you prove
it's not something that works it's not
something that you prove by creating
technology no rationality slash
irrationality is something you define
you defined what is your rationality and
then if it meets spec it's irrational I
mean a lot area a lot of kids behave
well because of Santa rooted far no you
did but but that's a that's a works but
he's irrational yeah and and and yes so
to behave but it's irrational and so
what I had to do was define
irrationality and I have defined it and
again it's that my son says you know
it's not really a definition its
criteria fine I am no problem with that
yeah it's a better waiting yeah yeah
well okay yeah but in a way it's it's
spec its specification you can score
criteria
name it any way you want but the point
here is that I'm giving conditions for
what we mean by irrational specifically
irrational and the first thing we have
to mention is that these definitions or
these criteria these specifications have
to do with theories and not with humans
we have a tendency to say I specifically
me I have a tendency to accuse people
being irrational that's my religion okay
do not confuse it with what I'm showing
here I'm saying this relates two
theories two explanations if the
explanation converts a concept to an
object or pretends to move it around and
transfer energy move a mass you know
extend the field all the way to eternity
won't be a more banal version that
people use like any transfer me the
money yeah again we should not confuse
ordinary speech because if you say
transfer me the funds the word funds is
is a concept but in ordinary speech we
have no problem with that believe me
there's no problem the problem is when
we when we good example the people can
but when we the problem comes when we
transfer this into physics now we can't
do that we can't in the nouns of physics
or object you can't say the word
movement or the word orbit funds
well yeah but let's let's look at
something more physical you can't use
the word you can't use the word orbit as
a noun in physics you can't say the
orbit of Jupiter you say Jupiter the
noun orbits orbits is a verb
and and this is where the problem we
need the comparison for funds well
transfer funds you can't say you can say
bills are being transferred then yes you
can see the bills the thought or the
coins now we got we got something
physical that's being transferred but
you can't say I transferred the funds
not in physics yeah okay you gotta say
bills are being transferred or fun or
you know coins are being transferred
then it's okay and physics we're physics
where we're extremely literal extremely
literal it's got to be literal and then
that's weird because because human
nature has this tendency to kind of been
through no no and the main reason for
that is we tend to put ordinary speech
into physics we bring it in and you
can't do that you can't say move a mass
you can't say transfer energy you can't
say that you carried a force or an
interaction or the field extends by our
definition that would be right because
you're using a concept such as a field
the mass energy as a physical object
then the number two there is that you're
using undefined words or or you know you
you're and these are critical words that
make or break your theory right so we're
looking at key words so you're you're
using undefined words or you use them
inconsistently and one of the main words
that are a couple of them are one is the
award object and the other one is that
word exists okay those two words are
dangerous you need you need more you
always need like a banal or normal all
day everyday example
that's your job oh it's my job okay well
anyways all I'm saying is you know the
word exists you know you know you see
atheists fighting against theists who
fight against the agnostics and they go
around in circles why they never defined
a word exist
they say God exists the other guy said
God doesn't exist well you know I prove
it look the the perfection of a flower
only God could have created that the
other guy said well look at all the evil
that's in the world that God create that
as well and they go around in circles
and forever and the only thing they have
to resolve is please define the word
exist once you define the word exist and
we're talking about definitions here
right we're saying once you define the
word exist in a scientific way that you
can use consistently irrationally you
know again scientifically then you don't
have a problem then you say God exists
by definition because because it meets
the because God meets the condition the
specifications of the definition becomes
a matter of definition right right then
we fight over the definitions do
different words and then you can you can
fight over definitions but not over the
existence of God I saw the longest
discussion about the yeah we don't know
what truth is the question is what is
truth becomes like you say truth is a
concept we find them yeah you get it
clear the first step the first step if
it's a crucial word define it otherwise
you're gonna go in circles because this
guy understands one thing the other guy
understands another thing and they keep
arguing they don't even know what
they're arguing about because they're
not agreeing on the definition okay so
definitions are important finish yeah I
like the Center for the question what is
because then if after that is an object
you point to and if it's the concept you
define it correct what is love we define
it what is truth we define wrong it's
wrong to say what I I keep saying no but
just please define is better than to say
what is because what I'm only a reverse
to watch if I'm saying when the kid
walks up to you
and again but he should be pointed to
that there in the direction that he's
using ordinary speech yeah but that's
the first stage but just but just to
clarify it when someone asks what is
electricity then I correct them and say
you asked a question in a long way
because it's not a what there's a third
thing though uh-huh
okay what's the third I think I think I
see the problem with the what is thing
because okay it's not that we only say
what it what is two objects it's because
if someone says you know what is
electricity
now you don't define it now they're
looking for an explanation for a
mechanism so what is it's kind of like a
wishy-washy well that's why I don't like
that I don't like the word what the word
what should be research in physics
physics physics busy in science yeah
science in general but physics in
particular I'm saying the word what
should be revert to reserved for
specific nouns of physics which are only
objects you can't say what is energy
because energy is not a what the
question should be please define the
word energy but now he raises a third
category ons here he says what is
electricity or please define an
electricity they're not looking for and
they're not really definite they say
what do you mean by what do you mean
what what is this process that you're
referring to please explain it to me or
a more normal thing
what is economy or what is gravity again
you don't define gravity you explain it
and so gravity is a theory not a
definition now that concept that you it
is a concept yes but it's not something
that you define if somebody you explain
you know but that was my point because
when they say what is gravity they could
either be asking for a definition or an
explanation okay right it's all says
what is gravity with these Domino's is
okay gravity is is is this pull
downwards right just what is the thing
that we would point to if it had shape
but then you have two issues with
gravity because you don't you don't ask
these questions
I'm not sure about like if you can say
please define love or explain love yeah
it's two different question yeah and
what is the wrong word what is like you
can say what is a chair not what is love
you love you gotta say is please explain
or please define love give me an
explanation for glow but a good example
to show that problem with what is is
what is God because they could be either
asking for your belief of God they could
be asking you about the definition of
God what is God if it's a cool object or
a concept so what is question yeah and
again the first the first step is to
define the word or determine the first
step I always say is the is to determine
whether it's an object or a concept
please tell me which one are you gonna
refer to and God is the good good word
because you know is got an object is he
a human being with a magic wand or he's
got a concept if he love intelligence
grace that's a different issue so if
you're gonna say well God is a concept
okay now let's deal with concept we
forget about object now we're going to
deal with philosophy okay so God is a
concept what kind of concept of God is
love okay fine what do we mean by love
please define love or please explain
love either cause or or the reason or
the not cause but the reason or the
purpose of love and then then then we're
gonna be more or less rash in talking
rationally we're gonna be understanding
what the other guy is proposing that's
actually a good break down of thumb for
for science conference or presentation
the more specific question yeah the
better yeah you say what is right right
and that's why I don't like the word
what in in these kinds of question what
should be reserved for object you can
say well you know what is the dog
then people say you know the the Martian
ass you said the word dog what do you
mean by though what is a dog then it's
about a quest but you but you can't say
I'm gonna define the word dog you can't
define door dog you point to him doesn't
believe me the other word you can't
define the word you can describe a dog
once you name what you're you know you
point a name what's your referring to
now you can describe dogs say yeah he's
white he's got brown patches he barks
you know you can do all that stuff but
that's a description that comes after
you name and point and so the best way
it should be treated anyways the issue
here was that this fellow you know he he
criticized you know what do you mean by
rationality and I did point him to
rationality and several others came over
and they said you know it's your opinion
what do you mean by rationality it's
like you know they don't read they just
want to argue web of explanations
because because the way your definitions
are set up I keep bringing this up is
there not just standalone standalone
exactly they're defined in a web so that
they all complement each other it's
worried the whole system makes sense
across the board so when they when they
say that's your opinion they're
basically saying oh that definition or
that way of looking at it only only fits
within your web yeah but they don't know
they're not aware of the web no but I
think that you haven't gone that far
that's what that's the the gut feeling
when they say yeah but that's just your
feeling like oh you can define it anyway
yeah but then that's when I point I say
you don't have to agree with my
definition fact I always say this and I
mean it you know you don't like my
definition come up with yours tell me
what your definition of that same word
is and that's where they disappear yeah
you know I haven't had a single person
come over and talk to me about what
rationality or irrationality is because
they can't define it if
define it rationally consider in
rationally by rational and mean that you
can use it consistently scientifically
I've got the definition and these people
they just want to say well this is
irrational that's a rational irrational
it's just their opinion and when you say
well what do you mean by rational that's
when they run away because they don't
they can't define the word in a way that
doesn't destroy their own religion is
[Laughter]
the time to kill these things you ask
them to define a word and then you're
essentially challenging their web of
definitions because you're challenging
their religion no but yeah but their
beliefs aside thing because when you
challenge one word one definition that
one word is propping up for other
concepts but yeah it all sincerity you
know it's always hard to just say ah
define the word in a way that we can
both use because they don't have a
system just like you said
in my case my definitions are related
you you know you need to define distance
location is based on distance motion is
based on location so is existence so
they're all related they all deal with
objects you know etc but these people
don't have that and they don't have a
system and that's where the problem is
the problem is that these people you
know they say well I don't agree with
you well why don't you agree with me
well I don't know I agree we don't agree
with you but you know I don't agree with
you because all the phd's you know I
love them man they've created all this
technology that's why you know in other
words they don't have a rational answer
to your question and they never will
because they have to create a system in
order to do so oh we should do tomorrow
no just to show what the process is or
what the process could look like well we
did that today what was the word
objective yeah we already did more or
less that but yeah it's it's not easy to
define words believe me but once you
define that word and you scientifically
that you can use it consistently it's
worth gold because now you have
something to stand on something you
solid on which you stand on and that's
the problem with all these people they
say well I don't like you calling me
irrational well I'm not calling you
irrational I'm saying that what your
your theory is irrational
well it's irrational because it's your
opinion well no I have a definition and
subjective and they said well that's
your opinion okay give me your opinion
what is your definition that's when they
fly away okay so we'll see you tomorrow
same time same station and we're gonna
continue with how quondam is irrational
that's what we're gonna deal with
tomorrow we'll see you then tomorrow
same time same station bye bye